special thanks to boxu for sponsoring
this video more on them later
i haven't made a dragon ball video in a
hot minute and just as i come back to
see how things are going the community
is on fire and because of one chapter
that was released during the granola
arcane okay well it's not all because of
that it's it's a long story but in short
this latest development could risk
ruining all of dragon ball but how you
might be wondering the year is 1990
dragon ball is at the peak of its powers
during the frieza saga and the very
first dragon ball z tv special is
released bardock the father of goku
appearing in just two panels during the
original manga's run bardock along with
his television special cemented the
saiyan as not just a fan favorite with a
harrowing backstory but also one would
serve to greatly elevate the main
character of goku and indeed the story
post raditz directly adding to the
notion that it's not what you are but
indeed who you are that ultimately
determines your fate but akira toriyama
couldn't just leave that alone he had to
put his own spin on it a spin that has
been spinning out of control since 2014
and over this short video i want to
illustrate exactly what the massive
potential problem dragon ball is facing
truly is and it all stems from a
character whose backstory stands to
impact not just the future of this
series not only the paradox character
himself but along with that teases the
collapse of the very foundations the
entire series we all know and love are
built upon so let's see if bardock is
really going to be the character to
ruin dragon ball
[Music]
before you ruin something there has to
be something worthy of being ruined in
the first place so what was it that the
fans loved bardock the father of goku
1990. let's turn our clocks back to
october 17 1990. our heroes are in the
middle of fighting frieza in the manga
all the while this non-canon tv special
gets released telling the story of how
bardock the father of goku tried and
failed to stop the annihilation of his
people at the hands of frieza while not
written by akira toriyama the story
itself bolstered many of the themes
expressed in the series while adding a
much more complex backstory to the
events of early dragon ball which by
extension helped the main character goku
largely the point of goku's character
during the saiyan and frieza's sagas was
to illustrate and highlight the
differences between him and the saiyan
race from which he originated that the
nurturing he received as a child from
the likes of his grandpa gohan and the
lessons that were imparted unto him
through his early years ended up being
the difference makers in goku's life
ultimately allowing him to achieve
heights that comparably cold raditz
nappa and vegeta couldn't reach despite
their elite status and while the tv
special itself isn't perfect with the
seeing into the future aspect of it
raising some red flags for me bardock
the father of goku still managed to
coherently tell the story of a man that
was once loyal to frieza journeying to
stand alone against him we learn about
what he appreciates what he dislikes and
we are shown how the saiyan's nature
helped to lead to their own downfall and
ultimately that effort and desire alone
isn't enough when you stand in
opposition to frieza all themes and
sentiments that are present in the
original manga ultimately offering more
depth to the story so much so that akira
toriyama really took notice up until
this point barak hand appeared in the
manga beyond raditz's comment that goku
looked like him but as a result of
toriyama's adoration of this tv special
he incorporated it into his very own
manga although only appearing in two
panels they depict the tv specials
events right down to the design he
himself had a hand in creating and two
decades later in 2011 toriyama would
once again reiterate his love for the
story with the following quote when i
saw the finished episode i remembered
feeling a good bit of admiration with my
work i prefer lighthearted fare so i
have a tendency to avoid serious
material even if i had written about the
same past it would have become much
lighter in tone by far thanks to this i
felt as though even dragon ball had been
given a little more depth however
another quote from that time also gave a
subtle indication as to what awaited us
in the not so distant future he said i
really like the story of bardock goku's
father it's quite dramatic and the kind
of story i absolutely wouldn't draw if
it were me it was like watching a
different kind of dragon ball in a good
way so i thought it was nice fast
forward to 2014 and we finally get akira
toriyama's take on the backstory for
bardock and the origins of his son
kakarot in the 16-page collection
entitled dragon ball minus and toriyama
wasn't kidding you should have gone for
the head
this was totally different to bardock
the father of goku and unfortunately not
in a good way released within giaco the
galactic patrolman's volume the contents
of dragon ball minus served as the first
indication that all was not well with
the character of bardock or indeed the
broader dragon ball world there's a lot
to cover concerning this short story and
while i will be touching on my main
issues in this video there's a 28 minute
long dissection of dragon ball minus by
the fantastic mr fusion that i highly
recommend you check out if you want to
cover all your bases on this material
however to cut a long story short unlike
bardock the father of goku from 1990
dragon ball minus isn't so much a story
as it is expository information that
changes her perspective on the greater
story of bardock and goku as a character
on fundamental levels with its main
issues arising not only in how it
disappoints us through bardock's actions
but more troublingly how it manages to
retroactively change our perception of
the main character goku i would argue
for the worse goku's pure-hearted nature
for the entirety of dragon ball stood as
a monument to what made him special as a
character having gone through all of
early dragon ball overcoming great
threats saving the world from countless
horrible monsters it was later revealed
by raditz at the start of the saiyan arc
that goku was intended to have been a
greater monster than all of them and in
fact should have laid waste to that
world by now however thanks to who goku
is he specifically prevented that fate
from befalling the world he now calls
home resulting in the climax of the
saiyan are concerning itself with a
clash of a lower class commoner
ultimately besting the so-called elite
or upper echelon of the saiyan race
vegeta once again thanks to who goku was
he was able to gain the skills that
someone like vegeta would never have
been receptive to learning in the first
place and would never have been capable
of making the friendships that would
make the difference in the end dragon
ball minus however strips the story of
this and opts instead to make goku more
remarkable and much more like a superman
type character it takes the lower class
warrior no one expected anything from
which made dragon ball z interesting and
replaces it with a main character who
was expected to be the way that he
ultimately was and changes an
unremarkable backstory into one that
specifically was special removing any of
the dramatic weight that existed there
prior to this reveal now there are
plenty of retroactive and broad changes
toriyama made to the story of dragon
ball during its run like raditz
revealing that goku was an alien the
entire time this absolutely changed her
perspective to what came prior to the
reveal however facilitated and added so
much more for the future of the story
comparatively this choice made in dragon
ball minus only served to detract from
what was there before without offering
anything new for the future that was
until dragon ball super the granola arc
2022
[Music]
before i go any deeper on bardock i
think it's time for a snack break thanks
to my friends over at baksu if you're
not aware baksu is a monkey subscription
service that delivers premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings straight to your
door from japan but what makes bok su
pretty sweet is that every month it
features a brand new theme that will not
only provide a fun little gourmet
journey through japan but also teach you
some of the fascinating aspects of the
culture the first one you'll receive is
called seasons of japan which is a tasty
adventure through japan's four seasons
to give you an idea of what a year of
bok su would be like but after that
you'll jump right in with our monthly
themed boxes this month baksu is
celebrating its sixth birthday and have
picked out its members favorite snacks
to include it's the sort of greatest
hits of what baksu has offered over the
years with some real celebratory snacks
i think for me my favorite was probably
the curry flavored potato snack i love a
good crisp and these ones are basically
giant ones like crackers that taste
exactly like that delicious katsu curry
sauce i had all over my visit to japan
looking into the booklet that comes with
each boksu it seems these are from the
aichi prefecture it's a pretty
informative addition to the box that
actually teaches you japanese words too
i'm sure the one piece fans watching
will recognize
it's an awesome server so if you want to
try some of these tasty japanese snacks
and support my channel click the link in
the description use my code not mark 15
to get 15 off your first boxu order
like no joke is actually really good
don't try it
[Music]
while this section has in my opinion the
most egregious implications for the
series at large i will say that as of
writing this video the arc itself isn't
yet complete and while it is unlikely it
is still possible for things to revert
and come around at the very end to make
sense but with that said what about this
new material is causing waves in the
community i have plenty of thoughts on
the granola arc at large as it currently
stands however i will be leaving that
for its own video once the arc itself
concludes for the purposes of this video
i will be looking at the contents of the
following chapters chapter 76 the fate
of the saiyans within this chapter
mineito reveals that bardock was the one
who saved both himself granola's mother
and granola in fact from the invasion
that devastated his people and world
chapter 77 entitled bardock father of
goku this chapter reveals how bardock
initially saved them and the
circumstances that followed leading to
granola's mother muesli's death chapter
82 bardock vs gas revealed through the
recordings of his late father's scouter
are the events that took place following
the tragic death of muesli and how in
fact bardock survived against what we
now understand is a viciously formidable
foe in gas and finally chapter 83
bardock vs gas part two this is the
chapter everyone has been arguing over
and really the majority of arguments are
concerning the wording of one line a
wish bardock asks mineito to make on the
dragon balls that wish as translated by
this being i'd wish that my sons end up
thriving on its face it's a rather
innocuous request one that's certainly
in line with the modern incarnation of
the bardock character however when we
pause for a moment and decipher what the
implications of such a general wish
might be the issues become unfortunately
clear that potentially the real reason
goku survived all those years through
the original dragon ball story would no
longer have been due to his skills or
approach to life but instead the magical
guarantee provided by some giant magical
space lizard that he didn't defeat these
enemies on his own or with the help of
his allies but he was instead destined
to defeat these enemies as the dragon
willed it to be so now when this came
out there were plenty of folks that
looked at the viz translation and saw it
as being far more ambiguous than what
i've described i mean thrive is a very
ambiguous word that's doing a lot of the
heavy lifting in this conversation and
so therefore it leaves a lot up to
interpretation it could very easily mean
that goku stood no chance of death
growing up and not that depending on how
you interpret the word thrive in this
context which is honestly a fair
argument that was until many other
experienced japanese speakers compared
the translation from viz with the
original japanese text and realized this
wasn't quite accurate to what was
originally said perms a respected and
experienced japanese to english
translator and fan of the series took to
twitter to provide a more accurate and
direct translation
that translation reading
i'd wish my sons grew up healthy or well
what was translated ambiguously in the
official release is actually rather
direct in its original language when
translated correctly and lends
credibility if not certainty to the
concerns levied against that wish prior
that goku's journey and success in
avoidance of death during his childhood
up until his death with raditz wasn't
the result of any skill or even his
biology at this point but potentially
instead the will of his father's wish
carried out by a magical space lizard
yes
i know
cringe
[Music]
prior to all of this in 2014 goku was
seen as a child no one thought anything
of someone that was utterly unremarkable
that was sent to a world to destroy it
but in an ironic twist of fate ended up
doing exactly the opposite and due to
those attributes superseded every and
all expectations after 2014 goku's
origin became that of a chosen kid with
special parents sent to earth to survive
and live out his life happily until he's
given a chance to show just how special
he truly is during the saiyan and frieza
sagas and following that we arrive in
2022 which has seemingly transformed the
character even further by not only
keeping all of the prior story elements
intact from dragon ball minus that i
hate so much but also added that not
only was goku meant to be the way that
he was not only were his parents special
but that bardock himself requested of
someone to make the wish that protected
goku throughout his childhood ensuring
his survival and successful fleeing from
planet vegeta and sucking tremendous
amounts of value from anything he
achieved all throughout the early dragon
ball run as he was effectively now
destined to not only survive but grow up
healthy or well that all the success we
thought he earned during those turbulent
192 early chapters of the story were now
utterly
meaningless
now
this isn't to say however that this is a
one-sided discussion online while the
majority feel negatively towards this
there are those that hold out hope that
the remaining chapters of this arc could
salvage something meaningful while
undoing the negatives many fear are on
the way carthu from carthus dojo posted
an interesting theory on his twitter one
that he admits is a long shot but is
still possible as of writing this video
once bardock makes the wish mineito is
left to deliver the wish to the dragon
but we never see this happen and so
therein lies the possibility for the
message not to have been passed on to
the dragon and for monato to instead
make his own wish for granola's future
this is a clever use of the existing
parameters of the story while remaining
in line with the themes of the granola
arc as a whole but only time will tell
if that bears any fruit my hope is that
it does but as carthy points out it's a
massive copium play and even if it is
copium and it does change the landscape
of dragon ball for the worse there is
one small upside uh hilariously this one
which bardock makes might have actually
had the unintended effect of explaining
away the main issue i had with the king
piccolo arc in early dragon ball where
goku's heart stops and starts again
randomly buying him the time he needs
for piccolo to be convinced of his death
if this wish actually took place then i
guess we can chalk that momentary hard
stoppage to that wish along with every
other near-death experience he has in
that part of the story that is all to
say that as of writing this video the
future and troublingly the past of the
dragon ball story is in a state of limbo
since 2014 every and all explorations
into paradox past have yielded less than
desirable results that not only alter
our impressions of a one-time fan
favorite character in bardock but also
serve to fundamentally and retroactively
make everything that came before that
much less interesting with the latest
information changing the series so
fundamentally it's becoming increasingly
more difficult to make any excuse for
this series there are those out there
that think there's still a chance that
dragon ball super fixes this and writes
these wrongs however that is looking to
be less and less likely as the weeks and
months tick on by leaving us wondering
how a character we love so much like
bardock acted as the vehicle by which
dragon ball was ruined
thanks for
[Music]
just can't watching
what you're seeing
[Music]